chuckle oh gee where do we fight over a
little bit or make this like an infamous
tree guy is the biggest thing everything
we've ever done everything I've been a
part of you guys this is a two-way
conversation you got questions raise
your hand we'll dedicate a portion at
the end in case your questions I think
you're going to be stimulated in a lot
of ways now for Gary I'm going to give
him a brief intro but you're going to do
it as well
first and foremost cell mate you know
just like a lot of guys exactly that
molding work when it's just you in the
backyard busting your ass this is what
you've done his whole life guy from
former Soviet Union immigrant
communities code and you're busting his
tail ever since took a family business
from three million and sixty million
legs out busted his tail then created
his own entrepreneurship company around
media which is what everyone you do
every time you turn your phone on it is
a global company he's doing multiple
things in the sports world entertainment
world storytelling world the most
important thing I love most about you
bro is that you want to give and that's
what kind of is giving you guys every
tool that we possibly can think of over
the next hour so first and foremost Gary
I want to know your mindset at a
youngster when you were a teenager when
you were 17 18 19 like some of these
young kids here before they got to
campus when you were like okay I'm gonna
go compete them to create something on
my own mine goes back first of all thank
you for having me mine goes back a
little bit further so I was born in
Russia I came to the US you know I
couldn't speak English went outside one
day when we moved to Edison New Jersey a
bunch of kids throwing around a nerf
football and literally I learned how to
speak English by watching the New York
Jets play football so like it's fun for
me to be here and like it somewhere
around third or fourth grade after
falling in love with the sport unlike
everybody in this room somewhere around
3rd or 4th grade I realized that I was
more likely to buy the Jets that to play
for them and so really by the time I was
in like if you go open up like fifth
grade yearbook
everybody's like occupation I don't know
why in the 80s everybody wanted to be a
[ __ ] architect but everyone's like
architect architect architect and mine
just says owner of the New York Jets
so 17 and 18 like unlike a lot of people
in this room as well because you
wouldn't have gotten here no matter how
good you are I was a straight DNF
student
right so education was the way out for
us immigrants so it was crazy that I was
so bad at school but by fifth grade I
was making two three thousand dollars a
weekend selling baseball cards I knew I
was an entrepreneur from the get before
it was popular and cool like it is now
and so 1718 I was like I didn't can [ __ ]
about girls I didn't give a [ __ ] about
school I didn't give a [ __ ] about
anything I was like I'm gonna go [ __ ]
work I'm going to put my head down for
[ __ ] five decades I'm gonna buy the
Jets and win seven Super Bowls and call
it a [ __ ] day but but you know like
you know what's fun to talk to athletic
I feel like you guys it might be
different but it's the same like I just
didn't care about anything it was like
this narrow like you know and what we
can you say that because how many of us
they weren't quite ready right I thought
the hardest part at least for me is an
asset in case you want to get your point
on is you're so focused to be great to
even get a seat in this room that you
have to be that dialed in and you're
crap sometimes you can benefit you got
to have a certain amount of total vision
you know I'm saying like we all do when
I was in high school I wrote down I want
to go to the NFL literally in a class
wrote down kept it in my back pocket in
my wallet all your different plays
elements humbly that's all I focused on
you know I'm saying and that was the
mindset you know what I mean but to his
point earlier it's like you know it's
not about just writing that down and
just kind of waiting for word to happen
like you know I mean there's a lot of
hard work to go get it
you know me but it kind of set me up
everyday like I had a mindset I have a
focus like I said I wouldn't focus on
other things other than what I wrote
down the piece paper you know I'm saying
so I think that's the key to remember
it's like you want you got to have a
certain amount of tunnel vision
you got to move at the same time you
want to understand the big picture at
the end of the day to the big contenders
day and our sport is we can't play it
forever you know I'm saying and Thomas
talked about it a week ago about you
know we all have an expiration date when
it comes to playing football
you know I'm saying but while we're in
it you know saying we're locked in you
know so that's the only difference
between being an athlete and kind of
different occupations is that literally
you can't not play this forever but
while you're in it you're in it you know
I'm saying so you got a grind like like
like there is no tomorrow the other
thing you guys have is it's the religion
of our society like when you're in it
you have unlimited leverage unlimited
and when you're out of it it goes away
you know I mean it's it's unbelievable
like I have no time I can't meet anybody
but I'll give you a quick little story
Dexter MacDougall third round pick of
the Jets and Maryland's he like hit me
up DM me on Instagram or Twitter or
something we have I said I was like look
you better take this meeting soon
because when you get cut because he
wasn't playing well I'm not taking this
meeting
so like the what's amazing about
football and sports and general but
football more than anything in America
like it's not only it's crazy when I got
older I was like wait a minute it's
better to be a businessman than an
athlete because I started meeting like
30 year olds who are done right and it's
like wow that's crazy your whole life
you've just been like this and then
you're so young and you've got to reset
and think about it different what's
crazy and you could probably speak this
better than I can
it's crazy how smart this generation of
athlete is they think about
entrepreneurship they think about the
platform they think about building their
brand they think about investing it's
crazy what's happening you to have a
better perspective than I am I've
reversed engineered it backwards but the
advantage back to these three letters as
you frame they're like the leverage of
this brand is bonkers yeah think about
it no no in college the best advice I
got from our fifth year senior
quarterback was get three business cards
every day after Friday
you guys had alums that one day
disabilities are doing amazing things in
the universe but those threes business
cards now are as many as you want to
pedasi in you guys don't know this about
Gary but he was one of the first
investors and all the things that are on
your phone or something Twitter we're
talking snapchat tumblr and on and on
and on his list
this is our insane that you saw early so
the goal for today and you walked out of
here is you think about okay how can i
cultivate opportunities while I'm a
student-athlete with those three letters
when I walk out of here
unlike unfortunately for KC he scores a
great touchdown in the Rose golden win
the national champions Michigan Twitter
in scam don't exist his platform is way
different than what it could have been
if he's worth the update last year it's
going to touch down in the road right
you've noticed obviously your platform
is altered and that is a beautiful
opportunity for you guys so I'd be
curious if you could give them some
thoughts on it's real simple the same
way you're slipping into the DM to get
something up there that to accomplish
you need to be doing for business it's
the same thing right it's your just
reverse engineering what you want you
just have unlimited tools unlimited and
so like everybody here is going through
their streams creeping on what they want
to do do that same practice for business
because you're right like it's crazy
what I'll do for the jet if panner
if Canaan perder [ __ ] DME right now
you're the long snapper of New York Jets
I'd meet them tomorrow if the CEO of 500
million dollar company email me tomorrow
it takes four months for me to meet with
them that's what you have and that's
crazy and you can map that
yeah I mean look I think first of all
the n-c-double-a [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
[ __ ] but you got to navigate through
that right like so you've got to be
careful and like that's you know coming
from communist Russia like [ __ ]
n-c-double-a scarier than that you know
like so you know you but but the reality
is that's your reality right like you
know that that's the reality but to your
point there's nothing against collecting
business card like it's only about
relationships you need to DAP it up with
as many people as possible that's life
is only about the people I made tens of
millions of dollars because I became
friendly I thought Twitter was going to
be important and I made those
relationships with those founders and
that's what opened up everything
everybody you talked to ever ever that's
made it that really made it it's just
relationships you missed some right you
go find my first book somewhere crush it
I thank my entire family and one random
person one Travis Cal connect founder of
uber my boy and I passed on uber twice
if I put in my normal 50,000 that I put
into companies I would have made four
hundred million dollars a [ __ ] up
right I missed it but having the
relationship playing checkers with him
at some conference was the reason I even
had that at-bat [ __ ] up but I got the
at-bat you right now in Los Angeles with
these three letters and for a lot of you
you don't go to the league and get
another one of those at-bat this is one
of the closest things to having that
kind of leverage this is religion for a
lot of people a lot of people that run
[ __ ] and your folks and so so my advice
is real simple to you know that was an
incredible advice by the fifth-year
quarterback I would meet every single
person psiphon and learn they want to
they want to see you because they want
to take a selfie and show their 14 year
old son they know you you want to see
them because you want to win life
I think it's you got to have a balance
to it too though because let's let's all
be honest in here like you have to be
able to balance it too because you guys
want to do one thing which is NFL right
most guys going here is to want to go to
the NFL but like we talked about the
other side of it is the business side of
relationship side the networking side
all right so how do you balance the two
well you work out you only can work out
so much so many hours in the day right
so it's like what are you doing on those
all those other times where you
challenge how you just on your phone
looking at stuff or you out meeting
people shaking hands or you just you
want to see what everybody else is doing
in the world you know what I'm saying I
and and I'm I'm victim of the two
because I watched a lot of his stuff and
especially in the morning and some of
y'all not since I was just in the
morning time I like to have something
that don't get me going through the day
that's gonna motivate me and that's
going to set me on that right path but
at some point you got I got to put it
down right you know I'm saying like I
can't just be a slave to this phone all
day like I got to actually go out and
shake somebody's hand go out and talk to
yogi maybe introduce me to somebody or
go out and have lunch with this person
so the other thing is is like it's
balancing the tubes because like I said
we work out six o'clock 6 to 8 maybe 6
to 10 you got class maybe you come back
and throw maybe you got study hall so
you got lunch at 24 hours and days like
everybody else you're almost like me I
can fight a lot different than his but
end of the day there is a window of
opportunity like that's all I talked
about right you got a window of
opportunity at some point in there to go
do something other than watch
SportsCenter or TV maybe that's having
that dinner maybe and say hey I'm free
at ATM tonight can we get together for
dinner you know I'm saying so I think
you guys live in a generation now where
it's a challenge almost to kind of
balance the two like like yo you saying
I ain't had it I didn't have that
problem when I was in college because we
didn't have cell phones and Twitter and
artists not a problem it's not a problem
it's straight-up ER - you wish you had
it you have it so good listen your
balance needs to map your ambition you
don't do anything you're talking about
here you don't I think I'm most
fascinated about is people run their
mouth and then they don't back it up
with their actions you know your balance
needs to be predicated on your hunger
I think it's a good point you guys are
also shuffles right think about the way
you were provided notes there and train
staff when you study the way you prepare
your self proclaimed hustle you love
that word in your world because you do
write so I think it's the idea I have
all these tools as a student athlete as
a football player if you see them play
out every Saturday see them play out
every day in practice how do they play
out in the other side of your hustle
how do they find what you're interested
in Sam we just talked earlier about you
love Christopher Nolan director there's
an element of that of okay cool you can
build your story that we all have around
elements that you're interested in a
curious period of your thoughts on how
these guys can shape their interests
into their daily reality which is the
voice that they have on the simple phone
I mean if Sam texts or dance anybody
they're replying like it's just
opportunity I don't know like for me
it's real simple like I think about
things in a macro there's seven point
seven billion people when I look at
these men's faces right now like they're
[ __ ] way up there in the ranking I
wish there was a world ranking of every
person and I wish you could see where
you sit right this second it would blow
your [ __ ] face off it would it would
blow your [ __ ] face off on how good
your life actually is it would be
humbling you get real hungry you'd
realize how real lucky you are and so
you know I don't know like I just can't
imagine Sam not having any single person
replied whoever like just that's just
unbelievable like that's special now
everybody's got their own personalities
I don't know Sam I don't know anybody
here like you might be introverted you
might be quiet you might be focused on
this you might be having family issues
you don't have that energy for that
there's a million things going on and
everybody's dome right now but it
doesn't take away the fact that this is
actually what's happening to your life
right now and you can speak to this you
both can speak to this that window
closes real quick that's it not just the
truth you guys both dive into the idea
of self-awareness a lot right we know
how we feel when I wake up to get
check-in
generic additional feelings my body
saying I think the same thing can be
said for your social and how you craft
the message that you want to be sure
because it gets picked up by guys like
me when I'm going to call your game gets
picked up by people like him obviously
the check by your coaches curious when
you've seen messages kind of bounce all
over the place or ones that have stayed
consistent because it's not as though
you become a rock star overnight right
sometimes people think that happen
people think that happen with his career
I'm clearly not the truth when you bust
your ass for so long thank me with Casey
Ellison may catch the Rose Bowl in Old
Country know you you've been doing every
night when you're on campus
curiously your guys's point of view on
shaping their story on their respective
social media platforms versus doing what
people want them to do on their social
media platforms I mean I think I think
the key is you trying to think about
being a coach right now because that
could be in the form of you the first
thought you have is your truth ah it's
just listen everybody sees everything
like everything that's going on is
happening right like as you know
probably both you know like two years
ago I bought a sports agency and I we
recruited a class last year so I've
gotten into this game that you guys now
know so the first year I was like
started recruiting right like just look
in people's names up like it's crazy
what kids do like like leaving comments
the way they treat girls on Instagram
like something like everybody sees
everything like people are acting like
it's not real like and so and you can
also tell when somebody like everybody
knows everybody social is like the PR
version of themselves right like we even
have people now make pretend they're
taking private flights right like
there's all sorts of [ __ ] going on so
there's cynicism on is it real is it not
what's it up to I what I would say is a
couple things
it's not about overthinking like I'm a
media company how do I do this right I
think once you start overthinking [ __ ]
it's probably like the way you think
about sports right let me start over
thinking you get slow and then you're
trouble right so overthinking is
disastrous too in the way you build your
image and stuff like that you just need
to basically what worked for me was ten
years ago I saw Twitter I'm like [ __ ]
this is going to be the next thing and
it started
the kind of transformation to the mobile
device and social media and I remember
thinking ten years ago like [ __ ]
everything I do is on the record
like there's no hiding anymore right
forget about you posting [ __ ] what about
when you're out everybody's got to
[ __ ] this is 24/7 so I think the best
thing is to just let it go
be you but also at the same time know
all eyes are on it so I think it's like
there's no private moment you know I'm
saying anymore and really with that
being said is like just understanding
that having that mentality and not
saying that you know you got to be quiet
as a church mouse and walking around
with you're letting all the way up and
whatever but at the end of the day you
you are being watched and followed you
know what I'm saying and when we're
talking about branding we're talking
about the USC brand we're talking about
Nike of a brand we're talking about you
as a brand you not I'm saying it is
going to be scrutinized to a certain
extent by others good or bad and you
want to be in control you know I'm
saying so when you press in and when you
put something out you know I'm saying
it's having that mentality that okay
what is the person on the other side and
although you might not mean for it to
mean a certain thing you're not a fan
that procession is not always valid down
fast so that's good in the best part of
it I think most people case take the
defense on this or the flipside like
some anybody here lob session great
[ __ ] post that [ __ ] because the day
you become eligible some reason being to
put you in a position to get 50k from
[ __ ] I know some [ __ ] fishing line
[ __ ] company right so like like to me
to me it's like you got to speak your
truth like you love Cheerios post that
[ __ ]
it doesn't mean dick now but then when
you go to the league it might and so
like painting your truth you know
everyone's like oh don't post something
like that's going to get you put on
blast fine like you don't to be levar
Bell like getting blown up like that
like I get it like all that but there's
the flip side which is the offense of it
and so like you should be thinking about
that you don't have to if you don't want
to do what I just said
cool like if you love every precious
picture on your Instagram and it's good
that's fine but you're leaving
opportunity on the table
every expedition like every Friday night
when I'm broadcasting when your games I
take five guys on both sides of the ball
and I can take a deep dive on your
social media and I can usually predict
your performance so it's a random one
word about a girl
Jerri self total disconnection what
happened when Thursday night on campus
if it's totally dialed in I mean you can
kind of start to tell and even if I'm
wrong it shapes a story that I'm going
to tell on Saturday when we go on there
and I've always found it really fun
because I'll go through it under the
completely just wrote that like if you
see us and that's a couple of my
co-workers I can't believe you just
wrote that what I want you to dive into
Gary next is you talk about how your dad
talked to you about the power of your
words I think it's a radical story
because you all have that power and I
think you can you'll be able to
assimilate this story to your own lives
I didn't see my dad and I was 14 because
we came to America
and he got a job as a stock boy in a
liquor store we had to make it so he
leave at 7 a.m. and come home at
midnight or 10:00 and I just never saw
him like straight up never saw him and
then he saved up enough money by his own
liquor store I was like I said earlier
real hustler kid lemonade baseball cards
car washing like I dripped your [ __ ]
flowers out of your yard and sell it
back to you I was really like
interesting anyway I came to the liquor
store when I was 14 and I was grateful
as [ __ ] I would say anything to sell
something anything
my dad's old-school Russian dude like
he's all about like you know and any
scariest [ __ ] and he kind of like looked
me in the face and said like he saw me
do something and he like changed my life
like I really believe I will achieve I
feel like I'm the cliche kind of that
guy that's like like slick and like like
pure DNA I feel like I'm that guy the
one that like seems fun at first but
it's kind of like a [ __ ] face and like
we'll do whatever it is for him I
actually believe that but I think I got
lucky enough that I have such a hardcore
dad that he remoulded me when I was just
young enough where it became my truth
and that's why I think so much good has
happened for me the contradiction of
like selfish and selfless like just
honorable but like storyteller like it
just worked out it just worked out and
so yeah it was it was the transcending
moment of my life
he told me word is bombed and like
[ __ ] yeah tour Matt I want you both
answer this the idea of the hospital
you know you referenced the founder of
uber clearly you have to know people
high up if you're in invest in other
social platforms or the snap and if the
young CEO guys it's not much older than
some of your seniors in the room Ouiser
commonality between some of those in
Casey for you you've seen at the highest
level of coaching and playing and if you
could boil it down into one of those two
categories just a husband Italian yeah I
think you know when I think about hustle
you think about sports right and think
about a hustle people now saying we
taught my hustle look at me that's like
that means we're getting there you know
I'm saying we're doing that last little
bit that extra right so you think about
hustle mentality it's like he's gonna do
what he has to do to get to where he
needs to be you know what I'm saying but
having that hustle mentality is saying
like if I want to hit my focus get into
the lead like I'm gonna put my us to get
to leave like how how am I going to do
that you know I'm saying if I'm going to
get a 3.5 if I want to meet
such-and-such and LA Live or whatever
and work for this firm or whatever how
am I gonna hustle do that because it's
not like I think your decision won't
happen like you have to navigate to it
you know what I'm saying and and hustle
in my opinion you know and I think about
hustle like I didn't have I didn't have
Jerry being growing does one I have like
with Diddy that's when I thought about
Diddy back in the day like he was the
ultimate hustler to me
Puff Daddy Diddy all right so when I was
coming in college like he was always
talking about hustle and grind and this
and that and in my and my mind was like
okay I'm not in the music world but I'm
in football how can I take that
mentality and put it over here so I'm
going to work out here at 6 a.m. you
know I'm saying I'm gonna go work out
later on over here with this person I'm
gonna study film on this like I'm gonna
get myself to the best of my ability you
know I'm saying and study and do all
things I got to do and that's what I
think about when I think about hustle
the common thing about all the winners
I've seen in life this is interesting
because this is probably not the best
advice for a complete athlete so but it
I'd like you guys to hear it I think
it's interesting I think they're the
people that bet on their strengths
and didn't dwell on their weaknesses I
think about myself and all the other
people that I think have won they zoned
in on their strengths you know and and
they they maintained their weaknesses
and I've always thought about that with
athletes too because I think about
business like sports I'm always
wondering like the guys in this room are
like you know obviously if you have a
fatal flaw that can't allow you to be at
this level or next level you got to
close the gap right fix that but I've
always wondered if the ones that really
excelled did they have the three or four
things that they zoned in that naturally
came to them and then they triple down
on that instead of looked around the
room be like oh that dudes better at
this let me try to get better when as
you guys know so many things in life are
natural I think we fight DNA a lot and
so I've just been very curious at a
macro level what's the difference in
life when you go triple all-in on your
strengths instead of dwelling on we
consist into instant feedback on for
that me or the football player my
strength compared to some of the dudes
I'll playing with like my strength might
have been blocking and we talked about
this I talked about this couple weeks
ago somebody on a little talking today I
was I was going block my ass off right
you know that would be the best block
everything I've been on been the best
block right I wasn't always the tallest
the fastest and whatever but I was the
best blocker and most consistent my
browser this way I had the most
consistent route now those are my
strengths you know thanks so those kept
me in a roll all the time on any team
I've been on that was my roll were you
crippled downing on or really like [ __ ]
I need to get a little fast like we're
like because it feels it feels like
you're more scared about what you don't
have because that could be the one data
point because the links crazy right like
the combine its Ludacris like the
decisions that are made of some [ __ ]
that doesn't even map to what's going on
like so his point that's another point
combine right and I'm not I'm not
advocating this I'm just telling you my
story what I did at the combine I didn't
do everything at the combine he bring
her because I didn't I only did my
strength why because I did I knew I was
gonna be in front of every team every GM
every scallop why am I gonna go out
there
and do get on stand on the box so they
want to see how flexible you are and I
know I'm not flexible I think you know
I'm saying so I don't want them to look
at me and say oh he's not flexible I
don't want to give them interest
negative to say about okay so I didn't I
didn't do everything of a combine and I
had an agent who savvy enough to tell me
like okay this is what you should do
this what you shouldn't do and basically
I did I double down on my strengths of
the common all ideas compound was run
route I didn't run 40 right out here you
know Sammy come here I'm like I said I'm
not advocating this area I'm telling you
my story I didn't like the timing of it
you know Cindy they shuttle you into
Indy you're in there you got to get
warmed up on their time when absent when
you're working out of here for pro day
you're working on your own time you kind
of got your own routine there it doesn't
feel the same so all I said is like you
know what I'm just going to run route
I'm going to stretch I'm gonna stretch
I'm gonna do my height way they're like
you don't want to get on the Box they
make you sit on the ground and they want
to see how to let like I don't want do
that so you wanna stretch I'm like nom
good I literally came there to run
routes why I just want to show my
strength by shorthand how many of you
guys hang out with people outside of the
athletic department and you'd say that
that population is more than 30 percent
anybody thirty percent of the people
you're hanging out with or more or
outside of the athletic department not a
lot when you look around right fur guy
who went to grad school here
Casey obviously went to school here Gary
you got a really diverse group I'd love
to talk about the opportunity I have on
this campus because you're around those
three business people don't have to be
three people that have creating fortune
500 companies I know maybe people that
you partner with said something smarter
when your podcasts would get to know
your roommate when you get to college
and maybe isn't a football player I
think there's so much collaboration and
magic on this campus that when you lean
it to someone maybe 180 degrees away
from you you might have the next over
and that dude might invest it okay I
think I think what the way my mind works
is I reverse engineer regret regret
scares the [ __ ] out of me like you I'll
give you a real weird thing to do if you
want to do something kind of off the
beaten path that will make you feel good
and you'll get even more in return go
spend one day in a retirement home go
talk to five nine year olds if you real
listen all you're going to hear is
regret they're going to talk about a lot
of stuff they wish they did and so for
me when I'm thinking about you you got
to keep up your grades to do your thing
you've clearly got a like you're busy
right because you're you know an athlete
and and a student there's just still a
lot of time that's put into Madden you
know there's still a lot of time put
into other dumb [ __ ] and how it plays
out
99% of the time is you're 29 and you're
like [ __ ] I wish I that's it that's all
that's what I trade on you know and not
because I'm smart just cuz I talk to a
lot of people I just listen I just write
like I wish I like you're right the
amount of people that are going to go on
to do things here but listen it's not
for everybody I don't wanna be the guy
sitting up here to 40 year old talking
to you me like say hello to people all
this dorky [ __ ] like I get it it's still
gonna play out that way though I'll say
this one thing I didn't I don't regret
anything by my football jersey you know
saying fortunately I was like I was
always committed and I was around group
of guys that were the one thing I do
regret though is that I didn't network
with people in my class as much as I sit
in you know I'm saying I knew people on
campus but just like what yogi saying is
that how many of your classmates are you
really cool with you know what I'm
saying like you guys come into class and
they want to say hello know they'll talk
like everybody else on campus has the
problem of having no leverage you've got
nothing but leverage you just got to be
like yeah my god you're gonna do some
environment you got me [ __ ] and that's
what I did nothing one thing I will say
I do regret some what is it I didn't use
the network you know I'm saying now as
I've gotten older you know I'm saying
now see buddy let's eat oh and this is
not a cheese I'm not telling you to put
it off to your 35 years old but with the
with the brand I am a Trojan for life
right so I can still tap into the
network to this day if I choose to now a
lot of guys former players they don't
choose to it much
or they say don't write but now I do it
a lot more you know I mean it might be
older guys that graduate or even some of
the newer generations tapping into the
network but while you guys are in it
though like you stand you you could be
chilling with the the next uber person
in class or whatever and that could be
your boy and you do go make it to the
league you have a little piece of change
and you can invest into that company but
the thing that the thing that kills me
is like look if you're an introvert and
you're shy that's one thing but if
you're rolling in there with your beats
on because you think you're [ __ ] cool
you're [ __ ] idiot because most of
those people going to beat you it's math
and that's just stupid
you know like that like when you think
about it when you break it down it's
fascinating like just because you're
winning 14 nothing in the first quarter
doesn't mean you're gonna win the
opening night is vision and you talk to
Eric Thomas before right you've had him
on your show yeah he's [ __ ] crazy
with my Resendiz video go viral it's
pretty rad and he talked about how all
the other athletes that weren't invited
be opening their chip just keeps growing
and all the other athletes the design of
us either keeps growing and all the
students that don't get these get their
classes first there chit keeps growing
and yours will always grow in football
we hope but does it keep growing another
way so a challenge maybe you for the
rest of summer take three students
randomly in three of your classes and
ask them if you're going to partner with
me on any idea part of anybody what
would it be and go up a 20 minute
conversation see where your mind goes
because it might go to what's next
and this is where I think technology is
an advantage because like I like the Wii
and I invested in all those companies I
trade on human behavior like I know that
you're going to be interacting with
Alexa and like your car like I already
know what you're going to do before you
do it that's why I make so much money
right so I also know that not everybody
here is going to roll up on people be
like yo but this is where technology
comes through like saying what's up to
three people if you're not going to do
it face-to-face do it on a DM like you
know who's like like I don't care how
you do it just do it I think
technology's the gateway drug to real
life interaction you know like
everyone's ago these kids they don't
have it I think they do
I attract you interact differently this
is how it is but then that's what means
to you having a cup of coffee or a
conversation so you don't have to like
hang you know like fine but you just
figure it out just get into that
conversation because you're right like
the quality of students that go to the
school that go on to do things even if
you even if you go on and have a
nine-year professional career a stunning
percentage of the kids that are in your
classes are going to create unlimited
opportunities for you that all you had
to do is say what's up when you had the
most leverage as a football player at
the school at this moment I'm curious
open it up a little you guys Bryce you
can just raise your hand calling it but
when you think of the internet what do
you think one what's the first thing
that comes to mind yeah information well
doc yeah right off you go anybody
communication this is the opportunity
summit
opportunity to get access now we're
talking yeah
hey thank you cool cool you've been
cutting edge on a lot of things discuss
all with Nick when you think of the
internet you've often said it is the
internet is where TV or to the radio you
know what do you think about it now
where it's going and how these guys can
utilize in their lives it's so crazy for
me right in 41 I'm old right like like I
remember the world pre-internet you know
which is just like so batshit crazy
because when I think about internet like
when you said it I was like oxygen like
to me it's just like it's oxygen like
there is no life without the internet I
don't think people understand like let
me tell you something you will do 25
years now you will wear contact lenses
and you will live in a real world in an
augmented world and in a virtual world
in 25 years from now when you'll be
young you will put on contact lenses or
something will the inventor will be put
it LASIK into your eyes and like the
same way all those snapchat filters and
all that [ __ ] that will be real life
there'll be a fourth dude right here
virtually or you can go completely into
virtual orbit like this should just
started like we just started like uber
and Amazon and Facebook and snapchat
that's
it's basic like your car's going to
drive itself for you you're gonna be
like lounging in your car like the
things we're going to be doing like your
your to your beer is going to be
reordering itself for you when you've
one beer left in your fridge it's going
to reorder it for you
you're going to have technology in your
body like all this plays out to the
robots killing off all of us we probably
won't see it but it's common and so like
this is just starting like think about
think about what was it and when we
laugh like that it's fun for me because
if I told you ten years ago like ten
years ago if you did online dating
you were a [ __ ] dork right like now
all that's going on is that that is the
infrastructure for it
right if you told a parent ten years ago
here's what's up your fourteen-year-old
daughter should go into a stranger's car
to get around everyday they would have
laughed you out of the room that's what
uber is so like I don't think people
understand like what I think about the
internet I think about it as oxygen it's
just a framework that we now play in and
when you and to make it real life for
you instead of some heavy [ __ ] the
opportunity for all of you is
exponential it's so compounded you can
network in LA when you played here you
can network with the [ __ ] world you
can literally go on your phone right now
put in hashtag USC see anybody that
gives a [ __ ] about it and you can engage
with that and basically have anything
happen if you choose to that just
bonkers let's dive into the
responsibility that comes with that when
that happens it gives you can carry
tonight job in case you run for a long
time you're amazing at this you guys
remain you be superseded to be really
authentic like you haven't varied even
though cuz I know I can't hide like you
just not to be able to hide right and
that's because because we live in a
world where dant Danny Amendola the
night after winning the Super Bowl bang
some chick and she uses it as their
tinder profile like we just live in a
world where you're on the record right
why all the think on top of that like
say you did perfect PC posts
at some point you got to become your
voice you know which is all we asked you
guys to do that your story tested every
single one of your snapchat when I look
at some of you on snapchat versus
Twitter it's like the two different
people it's not Jeff I'm in your work
I'm in it real time and I see what's
going on on Thursday or wherever you may
be and on Twitter you might just say
something really nice about a teenager I
should offer be up for award right
but everybody's full of [ __ ] you ever
look at Facebook everybody's got the
best marriage best kids best vacation
like everybody's PR and the [ __ ] out of
themselves so what happens is
everything's about its sports everything
is about adjustments right tight ends
become [ __ ] basketball players you
got to adjust the safety position like
everybody there's a reaction reaction
social media didn't exist it came out
everybody was saying everything then we
got condition that people would react
and all of a sudden we got weird and
sort of PR in ourselves now everybody
knows that everybody's full of [ __ ] so
there's a counteract that's how snapchat
happened everybody shared everything
where was the opportunity something
private so like everything's about
countermoves like right now I don't give
a [ __ ] about social anymore because
everybody's on it everybody's looking
that's why I'm looking at voice that's
why I'm looking at smarta fication and
Internet of Things because everybody's
looking you got a problem right and
that's what's happening with social
nobody believes when I say I'm watching
what you guys are doing I'm not paying
attention to what you're posting I'm
paying attention to what you're double
tapping you know like it's so funny guys
are like PC and themselves on Instagram
like me my mom and then they're like
[ __ ] double tap and every chick on
the [ __ ] Internet right like like so
like you know like it's real funny and
it's real true that's why everybody's
lab because everybody knows and and it's
real [ __ ] great I love it
Casey what did you notice
double tapping right now Casey if what
you've noticed as a coach I mean you
recruit the entire country you guys are
lucky enough to be here and have a
scholarship offer or be on this roster
when you're diving into next year's
class the next year's class what are you
receiving what are you pulling from
these kids that are trying to PC on one
side and double
today let's add something on the other
that's the point thing I think for for
me especially being younger and kind of
in social media like mostly alright when
we see recruits or we see y'all you know
writing certain things or doing certain
things and and and like you're saying
that's not true not I should say it's
not true but you end up you see another
side you know I'm saying that you get on
campus or you or your parents are around
so now you're the recruit and you got
both parents in here so now you're all
you're sitting straight you got this
like Brian was on you okay no I'm saying
so it's like we we understand what the
real is you know and the whole facade is
like it's really there's no point of it
like you said it ends up coming out you
know what I mean like people will know
if you're authentic or not and whether
you're really not so you know at the end
of the day you know you can try to like
kind of dress certain things up but I
think that's from a coaching standpoint
you know especially when you're you guys
are already our players we try to
protect you in the sensitives which your
educates you on what you're posting and
all that type of stuff but for recruits
you know we're kind of looking at them
and kind of trying to see what their
mind is where their mindset is because
we do understand once you gotta get on
this campus it's gonna be all the
distractions and you know you got
parties you got girls you got alcohol
you got all kind of other stuff so we
want to know or we try to anticipate if
that athlete might be have a problem you
know I'm saying or might dive in the
problem with even once they get to the
yeah okay well the reason I ask you that
is to give you the idea of recruiting
right whether that's and then it's so
executive here we have over a thousand
employees and all your companies
combined right the recruiting side of
thing never really stops so I want you
to dive back in to something said
earlier you said you're going to be you
you're going to be authentically you
give these guys a strategy on their
social take take it a step further I
think they're better off being them like
you're 18 19 20 21 year old alpha male
dudes like there's you know what you
don't know at 19 20 you know that's like
when you're 41 you're still 20 like
you're not tricking anybody and they're
empathetic they know who you're supposed
to be like as long as you're not doing
something crazy murdering [ __ ] Pete
like you know as long as nothing crazy
[ __ ]
like I actually think people should go
more into who they actually are because
people know that's what you're supposed
to be anyway like you're so worried
about the edges right like you're
supposed to be can I say this it kind of
ties to him I swear to you about a month
ago so I wanted his videos for the first
time right and I'm like this boom got
got my hair standing up right and I got
to the point I was like the ham I wonder
I want to repost it but in my head and
Mike I had my coaching hat on I was like
damn he's cussing up and I was thinking
like well what if appearance of recruits
parents is on my page and their life and
you know at the end of the day you know
I said [ __ ] it [ __ ] it and I were to
close it straight up
you don't think because in my head I'm
like if you refuse a kid because his
mom's mad that you know that you
reposted a cursing video that [ __ ]
should have been at USC anyway that was
the point so to meto I'ma be honest with
you the true story three chances I
believe that I love it here right but
true story I was like damn you know I'm
saying like I'm supposed to be an
example for y'all I'm a blonde I'm like
you know everything I put up and you
know this that like I'm not gonna put
the torquing video of right you know Sam
but he's actually saying something
that's dope because he says f-word right
like does that make it wrong man and
things are getting redefined right like
look what you know like rich people
dress differently like like here's what
I always worry about you're trying to
get positioned for the world that you
think it is but then the world moves on
you like all all those 40 year olds they
got straight A's that came up with me
and went to Princeton and went to [ __ ]
Wall Street and everything they all DME
they're like [ __ ] and I'm like yeah
because you thought the world was going
to stay still
by the time you're 25 27 doing your
thing the world's going to redefine
Facebook's going to come out and
entrepreneurs are going to wear t-shirts
and sneakers that's not what I grew up
with it's not what's 41 year old looking
dick of [ __ ] socks and [ __ ] like
that that wasn't real like the world's
going to move the Mendoza line doing
what by me Cyrus dudes working on MTV is
lame compared to every [ __ ] post on
Instagram now the world rubes
so trying to
form to me the reason I am me and I do
much money I lose for cursing for
example being a company not give us a 5
million dollar account because somebody
on the board didn't like that I cursed
good like because I got plenty more
money in return for actually being
myself and again you can't break rules
and all that that's just the way it is
right but like being yourself always
plays out always plays out you know when
we need to talk about that that's my
first career are you 21 yet yes so you
need to be careful when are you 21 great
go [ __ ] crazy and March drinking of
it yeah are you like working at the
winery Sierra yeah and like and like if
you want to be triple cautious you can
be like can't wait to March when I can
actually start like you can play with it
right like you can be you can play with
it but like and you know wine it what's
funny about Y and you know this is like
it's definitely still not cognac or beer
like you're going to get away with it
it's more [ __ ] bougie [ __ ] you know
let me say let me say something to you
the truth is undefeated the truth is
undefeated like if you if your passion
about wine culture and you're not [ __ ]
drinking bottles to the face you're
going to be okay regardless of what
somebody thinks now let me tell you
something now that I've gotten in the
game a little bit these NFL executives
you can speak this better like they're
big boys and girls they're not real
confused nobody's not drafting you
because you put a [ __ ] picture in
Napa Valley
so like people I grew up with Barbara at
South Central
like so you know it's a lot of people
smoke drink party that's a nitro like
I'm posting my heart is on a publication
I keep it out girl ugly people cool it
and like on a page people kind of like
attack me get on surrounded for doing
the same thing like both save all time I
say personally and I'm glad I was
actually about to go there because it
probably do that and I'm glad you
brought that up to me personally I don't
think this you should hide from it just
like he's saying you know I'm saying
there's no need to hide from that
because there's nothing wrong with it
that's where you grew up right now I'm
saying you're not engaging you're not on
in the video with a blood in your hand
or drink you know what I'm saying like
I'm not saying that but it it's nothing
wrong with like those being some of your
your friends you know the fan and having
a relationship with it you're not I mean
in my opinion no you might you might
tell me I'm wrong you might be wrong you
should go look at Robbie Anderson he's a
wide receiver for the jet I think he's
done it real smart like you can tell
that's his crew where he came from but
the pictures he chooses to put up there
they're you know like you got to be
smart about the settings of it right
like outside in the barbecue cool like
everybody [ __ ] blunt to the face
playing video games and there that's the
background of your picture with them not
going to work just not you know that
right so I think I think you can't hide
from where you Kate like nobody wants to
do that in your situation but you know
people are going to make assumptions I
don't think you'll get hurt like by
looking if somebody goes down the rabbit
hole looks at all the kids you tagged
and they're doing all that in their
photos I think you can escape that if
you're smart about how you position the
content with them go ahead
Fars Twitter like say somebody like they
got you some stuff like oh like what's
going on tonight now I'm trying to turn
up like and you kind of force to kind of
reply if you are put on a platform to
like you know you like how do I apply
this directly I want in a Girl Scout to
be like oh I'm not to go party
you always got it I feel like you always
have an out but you don't work well you
know forced to do anything yeah I may
not that order my manly you can go
directly I think we're gonna be at 33
tonight oh yes as opposed to the big
social thread where everybody's like you
know say I'm like there's ways around it
up you know me like and not like he's
saying they're big boys and girls up
there they don't understand that that
NFL college people are gonna go out and
have a good time he was just 4th of July
everybody had a barbeque everybody had a
probably a drink I don't really drink
but everybody had a drink in the hand
for the most part like this in the world
in general right so the fact they're
like you might be if not 4th of July
it's not a holiday it might be just a
random day or your friends might be
doing on a random day or you going out
on a Tuesday like listen you people need
to be smart in this room like I got more
air cover than you because I'm a
pathetic coach and I sled this listen
dudes are punching girls in the [ __ ]
face and going in the second round like
let's let's let's talk like let's let's
let's talk real talk like like you need
to be smart if you've got all the pieces
in place that makes you a first-round
pick you know exactly the truth which is
you can get away with more [ __ ] if
you're [ __ ] fringe seventh round you
DFA you better be really [ __ ] smart
if you want to be in the league that's
just the truth might get me in trouble
but it's the truth
like you'll never get ever penalized for
somebody you know someone take that
tweet and have it be three people hold
and [ __ ] an ounce of weed and you still
won't get in trouble for that because if
you it's that I'll give the same advice
over and over and I've really dissected
this now the truth is undefeated you
don't need to have a social media
account if you're [ __ ] smart and coke
in the bathroom you're going to lose
have you got
the answer how and why all the NFL
objectives I talked to do when they eat
stuff like that they were going a rabbit
hole everybody attached to it they learn
all about it you can stand right in
front of them if I'm Carol Schneider
named NFL coaches why just kick it with
them I've known them forever what is
your relationship how do you operate
when you're around them if you can
answer those well and it's not I do
participate in those activities when you
go down that rabbit hole and find out
what they're about then you're good if
you do participate then don't engage in
that relationship because this point is
fair the truth will always come out
hundred but I always go back to how I
want it how I operate is journalist how
I try to offer my life you can answer
the question how why you're even in this
chair right now how why you kick it with
somebody how and why you're dating
somebody how are you respect that girl
then you're good if you can't answer it
or if it's [ __ ] and it's not the
truth then I think you're in a world of
hurt and your life's probably in a world
of hurt you gained probably the world of
hurt and you're probably going to be an
objective creation so like when he's
talking about like scallops and all that
combine stuff a lot of times at the
combine and in a film they're going to
ask you questions as they know the
answers to I just want to know if you're
going to tell the truth I don't want any
of you gonna tell the truth you know a
hundred percent there you're going to
know if you've tested positive or they
don't know if you smoke and all this
stuff and they're gonna say hey you
smoked and you're gonna be like nope no
I don't know I've never smoked but they
already know the answer they see is he
lying no I'm saying if you're telling
the truth yeah I used to smoke there's
this one time you know or I used to
smoke I grew up I would lie this
neighborhood and I smoked but you know
what I stopped you know I've been
training for the combine I've really
been focusing past year you don't think
they want to know what you're gonna say
how you gonna react to it so I don't to
the point of like those being your
friends and all that like it is what it
is like like Yogi's hands they're go
they might ask you about that when it
comes to the point you might say well
yeah you know how to love in South
Central and this is the black I grew up
on and these are the boys I grew up in
the street playing football with you got
that got me to this point
you know I'm saying these are my boys
like and then they might walk me like
man
that's a loyal dude man he's 100%
nonsense though they might take that you
might look at it like damn it looks bad
me but they might say like that's what
well you don't
well you don't know even as you get
older the cover-up and the lying is
always compound like there's only a
couple things the most extreme things
that are worse than the lie because then
that just breaks the trust and then
they're just scared about everything
I mean smoking or hanging out with the
wrong and that's that's the norm they
know that they're not naive you think
you're tricking them you think you're
tricking a multitrillion-dollar
organization you how are you guys you
with this Grange in your room get the
[ __ ] out of here I wanted to deal with
this at all in case you probably know
with this as well as you get older you
do relationships involved in high school
through college your professional
careers sometimes you'll just move on
and you're around an environment that
may take you to different rooms
different places different businesses
different teams and that's just a
reality of when you go out there and I'm
curious did you probably dealt with a
lot of your boys from whether I went I
went to Mount Ida college fifty percent
of the kids in my college went to jail I
want to I've slept with my wallet every
night I'll be everybody in celo and
spades and all that [ __ ] in here like I
went to a Hood College Oh like I keep in
touch with those friends but when I
started my business I wasn't taking any
of those [ __ ] gangsters in it then my
boys and I'll help them but like when
you you know like that's life right like
that you know that is the cliche
conversation I had a weird businessman
conversation like that but the cliche
sports conversation is you know like
kids come from rug's neighborhoods and
things of that nature and you could
still be tried and true but you know
what's tough is like what we don't talk
about now is post that last collective
bargaining agreement like rookies aren't
making that much money like you're
making money I mean when you got nothing
hundreds of thousands is real but like
you sort get you you guys everybody
knows everybody knows the story is like
you start getting those 47 phone calls
Jalen reeves-maybin right line back from
Tennessee kid that we represent a
lebanner sports fourth round pick
his phone blows up when he gets trapped
at fourth-round
you know the economics of that now look
like like so it's tough and so like yeah
life evolves but there's ways to be
there for people without just being
their piggy bank and it's tough man like
like I don't I don't sympathize with
like everybody coming at you like that
kids that have been with you in rough
spots from a long way
family members family members that helps
you it's hard but that's what being a
grown-ass man is about like if you
actually can say no for the first three
years put into work state you know you
know what stuff you get to the league
and you think that was it right like you
know it's not but you still think it is
because now you know I school of course
you get to this you got the [ __ ]
[ __ ] n-c-double-a so you still not
making back now you're in the league
right and you feel like at some level
you've made it but the truth is the
money's not there until that second
contract that can really get you to be
like right so the key is actually
locking down in those first couple years
and really being smart with those making
those right investments hopefully you
stay healthy and get to that second deal
you say I'm honestly listen like
honestly I think sometimes you should
give it to like like that like you gotta
be you like listen I don't know like
money like I just love the game of like
I it worked out for me but I was not
making a lot of money in my 20s and 30s
and I was like helping my friend like
this whole so I didn't take moose or
Tokyo Joe or [ __ ] Dustin to my
business but I was wiring them money my
friend Dustin [ __ ] was bringing so
much ecstasy from [ __ ] Holland to LA
you can't imagine what to jail you need
to help like I gave a money like like
I'm not going to judge you because some
guy that was had your back from the get
needs money and you're worried about
some executives or people judging you
like I think it comes down to
individuality here right I think it's
okay and like look I think it's
everything becomes the product of your
reality right first round quarterbacks
get paid different than fifth round
cornerbacks like there's just
everybody's got their real life and so
like there's different pressures and
then some families first-round
quarterback doesn't have those pressures
at a 5th round corner everybody around
them feels like it is the first pick of
the dressers a million different things
here I think the key for all of you is
you need to be good with yourself first
because then you'll have the strength
for the yeses and noes that will dictate
the [ __ ] outcome of your life I think
that's key though like being able to say
no and and yes because you are going to
say yes at times and you are going to
have to say no and harder to say no that
is to say yes you know I'm saying you
don't get asked for random and crazy
stuff just and and you gonna do it
sometimes sometimes you might not even
feel like you should do it or you really
want to do it you'll do it anyway 2%
I'll let it go
but there's gonna be some times where
you don't say you know what man I can't
do it this time
or like a man you know and that's when
you find out what's really happy to put
somebody on twice and then you say no
the third time reacts after that if they
still with you they still you know
saying the National folks because at the
end of the day like if you helping
someone you help them out
I learned something long time ago like
my pops Comey said don't give something
to somebody that that really you can't
do it out so if he tells me I'm alone
I'm alone $100 he tell you can give it
back to me and I'm gonna trust him to
give it back if I loan it to him my head
I'm like man you know what if I don't
I'll own this hundred if you don't give
back to the uncool you know what I'm
saying like and if he gives it back to
me cool because he said he will he said
he would never like say this top spin on
him shove my hand you know I'm saying
but if he doesn't give it back to me I
can still function and working and I'ma
be good but at the end of the day too
even on the side of giving it you know
sometimes you got to just kind of like
distance yourself you know I mean and
just kind of you'll read people and
understand and you'll see when it's a
real situation when it's not a real
situation and then it'll be opportunity
for you to help them grow in situations
of you know what what's the thing I've
sniffed out real quick from the outside
veterans when you get there it's been
interesting that some of the kids that
I've been [ __ ] left there like the
veterans were the ones that gave them
the courage because you know like
they're in it right you can look at that
guy right next to you Locker who's in
your nine like I would tell you know
this is probably what happened here too
and you guys could all speak to more
than I can that's why I go hang out with
90 year olds you learned so much more
from people that have been it through it
and did it than anything else so if
you're lucky enough to get to the next
level and deal with some of those
pressures I would attach yourself to
that while Yvette being be that annoying
rookie and get all that wisdom and that
halo that protection to kids have
already told me the reason they had
courage to say no was they leaned on old
man him old man thirty years old but you
know you know to them so that's
something to think about from a strategy
standpoint sometimes of tools is
learning how to do
learning how to say it like wonder it's
like framing it and it's an answer and
you just stick to it like you know my
budget is set this way you know saying
I'm allocated to I got to do this like I
do this I can only give out so much like
and then a few just stick to it and
that's your answer and then you they're
gonna say well I'm gonna give back in
like well you know you just gotta stick
to it holler happily is until you tell
somebody no and you can't do it they're
going to come with another plan for why
you can't do it and well how about this
much and where they go they're gonna
come they're gonna come with something
else he's gotta just stick with it you
know think of this it's hard like I said
it gonna keep coming you got to stand
firm be like man I can't this time you
know I'm sad like you know if I could up
no I'm saying I mean I can but it's like
my situation doesn't allow me yeah I
might financially I might have it
literally in the bank but I just can't
do it you know I'm saying be put because
my overall picture my goal and I'm
saying like the carry Cobra plan or
whoever we are like it just doesn't sit
with it and everybody's reading
headlines right that reading what Google
told them about your contract they're
not looking into what's guaranteed
they're not looking into the costs now
to maintain your body like there's just
like right like one of my favorite
phrases we could disagree or may not I
love you hundred percent what questions
I want to ask you both you guys when you
look at competition how do you frame it
and I say that you may not know this but
I encourage you to check it out as a new
show on Apple music called planet or the
apps for basically somebody comes down
with 30-second elevator and they
literally have a pitch on the new app
and it's Gary one of the judges Jessica
Alba Gwyneth Paltrow will I am pretty
cool show but that's one of the more
competitive industries and you guys
probably have a boatload of how to be a
so I want you to leave here with okay we
just got a lot of knowledge how can I
put this together in one of my gigs one
of my collaborations with a friend or
with one of my teammates so I'm sorry I
apologize I want to make sure I
understand question I want to see how
you view competition could you see it on
a show where people are little icing
coming up with some more
creative ideas and maybe you've seen I
mean I spend no time on competition
I don't think about competition I hate
my competition I want to slice their
[ __ ] throat I but I spend no time on
them I got no time for them because I'm
not worried about them we'd do my thing
and I'm gonna make them react to me I
like dislike I love when I meet business
people that I'm supposed to know and
they can taste that I don't know who
they are you know when you know you know
when you know and like a nice to meet
you I love that feeling that they know
that I don't know who they are even
though I'm supposed to because that's
how much I disrespect that [ __ ]
because I'm in my [ __ ] I'm in my [ __ ] by
the way doesn't mean by the way she
remade BP and by the way I'm good with
that because that's the game you got to
take your else I wear my loss on uber or
my other like I [ __ ] own my else but
they're mine right and so my only driven
by competition like I'm a business I'm a
businessman because I wasn't gifted with
your guys athletics and I needed to get
that nut off in a different way and that
was business right and so like I mean I
I made when I was making $80,000 a year
that was enough for me to live I'm not
[ __ ] fancy I came from zero I don't
need [ __ ] I don't need a watch [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] like that
I need the game and my game is business
and the way I treat it is I'm gonna do
me and I'm gonna make them react to me
I'm not going to [ __ ] watch them on
them you don't get away with that you've
got to watch but I get it's different
but like for me I don't have to watch
film I'm gonna do my [ __ ] and I'm going
to do it so [ __ ] hard and so loud
that I'm going to make them spend time
focusing on me instead of the reverse I
think for me like and I've talked to
Dion say about this like farce
competition now we're talking about I'm
a receiver and I have other receivers
that I'm competing it in the world like
you know say we're getting ready for the
draft and they got me raised at the top
seven seven receiver and I'm there six
other guys in front of me I'm not
looking at them six guys like he's
saying because I'm worried about myself
we're all different individuals now when
it comes to like the reverse competition
like when I'm getting ready for a game
you're not I'm saying I'm going to
respect the person I'm playing against
but at the same time like
I know that if I'm at my best and I'm
prepared you know I'm saying like it
doesn't matter who I'm playing against
you know you really have to have that
mentality especially if you want to play
on Sundays because on Sunday you're
gonna be playing against somebody that's
somebody every week so whether it's
Champ Bailey this week and Asante Samuel
this week and it all matter you playing
against somebody so it don't that name
it does that don't matter I already know
he's going to be at a certain caliber
and level I just know that I got to be
at a certain level myself and how do I
get myself there by studying him as a
number okay that's a lot of talking
gonzo is this how you like to step it
has a line of scrimmage and he likes
that hard press he likes to whatever it
is as an individual I'm getting to know
him but at the end of the day I'm
already constructing a plan in my head
like this how I'm gonna tackle you know
I'm saying because it's really about me
though it's not about him it's about me
beating him you know I'm Sam so because
what's great about sports and business
is it's gonna play out
there's no subjectiveness in what you
guys do for a living
somebody's going to win somebody's going
to lose like that's why you got to focus
so much on yourself because it's not
subjective it's not a painting or a
bottle of wine they're like a couple
critics or like it's good it's bad it's
like why he's a lot of fun because it's
subjected that's why I did real well in
it because if I story told well you just
I made you think it was good before you
[ __ ] drank it we don't have that in
business in sports like if you lose 31
to 7 you [ __ ] lost like there's no
like no so so that's why it's so insular
right like back to what connects me with
this world I don't know anybody in the
sports agent world like it owns like oh
do you like I don't know anybody I don't
know single [ __ ] name I don't give a
[ __ ] about athletes first or [ __ ]
rock nation I know Shore no jay-z is not
doing [ __ ] right like it doesn't matter
I have to do my thing and so like that's
that's how I think about competition
before we let you go
clearly very cases you guys are known
for a while you guys live on that
razor's edge I'm curious how you
cultivate Andry cultivate that every day
for you I mean for me like I said I'm
not playing anymore right so I have to
recreate some type of way that's why I
said in the morning if I send you guys
something the more inspired because I
just watch that [ __ ] and I'm my date I'm
trying to get my juices flowing
y'all going to get into workout you're
going to get on field you're going to
put your helmet on like there's certain
things that's going to happen in your
life or that you guys are doing like
playing sport that that juice is gonna
flow naturally n'gatu like created I got
to create it I got a manufactured a
little so I'm watching his video you
know I'm saying I might be watching ET I
might watch whoever you're not I'm
saying and for me I do that because I'm
setting my mind like he will he know we
talk all the time we send each other
videos quote pictures I mean that's my
other brother back there right so we
stay on each other because if I see
something I like that's gonna get me
going you know what I'm saying like
that's how I'm kind of trying to create
it you know me so you guys live in the
world where naturally if you got like if
you're a self-starter
I consider myself a self-starter when I
was in a workout I didn't need the coast
like you know my ass and yell at me and
tell me get going and like once I was
out there let's go this goal time you
know saying so I feel like you guys are
kind of in that world where yeah you
might have turn the music up it might be
a song you know SAS
why is everybody turn the music up in
the weight room because they want to get
hyper you everybody listen to headphones
before the game because they want to get
to stuff like naturally like I'm ready I
listen to music or game but really I can
just go out there and play let's go
you know saying but nowadays I'm doing
stuff like I'm watching with other you
know it might be something that he's
saying it might be something somebody
else is saying that's going just kind of
stirred in me because it's in this you
know I'm saying I got that natural juice
that competitive nature in me it's just
going to stir it up and that's all I
need to go for me it's gratitude I'm
super grateful man like
I was born in the [ __ ] place got out of
Russia when nobody was getting out right
like got lucky like I'm grateful like if
I wake up and everybody my family is
alive I'm so [ __ ] fired up I don't
want [ __ ] I don't listen to [ __ ] I'm
just like I'm so grateful you know yogi
like I look like I just know you know I
don't know what else to say I'm just
super um part of this nonprofit pencils
of promise I took some of my people run
to Ghana with the Ghana land in the car
and then throw for hours this piece is
where people walk an hour to get fresh
water that man's water bottle there they
would [ __ ] die for that [ __ ] like I
just think everybody's lost perspective
and I'm real empathetic this one's lost
perspective you're a football player USC
your perspective is broke it just is so
like I try to unwind like my
perspectives I'm a white man in America
and I'm rich as [ __ ] my perspective is
broke so I'm trying to rewind it back to
just be grateful I'm just grateful so
the way I stay on the edge and just like
gratitude
it's just gratitude like one life one
at-bat one time I just don't want to see
that regret in my eyes that I see in so
many and that's why it's so fun for me
to come and talk to you now because like
straight up for 90% of you this is the
greatest year of your life right now
that's just the truth to be mad at me
you can be sad at me you can think I'm
stupid
telling you straight to your [ __ ]
faces for 80 to 90% of you this is it
this is the [ __ ] pinnacle so you
better squeeze the [ __ ] out of this
thing because if you're smart and you do
then it won't be it is it's cuz it's
true you know like it's not like I'm
smart I'm just looking at data
I'm just looking at history just talking
to people just being a student of life
it's true as you kind of wrap this thing
up and guarantee see myself we're gonna
hang around if you guys got any other
questions I think there's dinner for you
as well with these two guys do Casey
no no for 10-15 years now Gary just
observing his content from afar as they
give and coach Carroll is the same way
when he was here he just gave and gave
and I think that's really the lesson the
more you get it's going to come back to
don't expected T was done in a million
times everybody in this audience has
done it when there's the kids whether
it's tyrion social whatever it it can
give you give the unique stuff away and
they'll come back in them you won me
over so big in this you said one thing
that i live on
I have zero expectation you know I'm so
happy I have zero expectation of others
nobody's ever let me down when I do I do
it
Gary Vee on Instagram and snapchat hit
me up
you need to sign with my firm you don't
need to be drafted by the Jets I will
give because karma is practical giving
is practical that [ __ ] always works out
that [ __ ] karma always is practical it
always works out so if I can help you in
any way Gary Vee anyway maybe you want
me to bet done good course you're going
to leverage it good ok alright so I
appreciate it I know you're kind of
precious of as is Gary and Casey give it
up
[Applause]
- community is given
it's only a boner if somebody comes Tony
[Music]